tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
movide sono vaghi j
ci siamo guardati rifaccio the world
hardesty game ii livello come non so che
impossibile la cosa più impossibile da
dire titolo ragazzi prima cosa lo sa che
in teoria non ho finito l'uno hardest
games o catene anche per arrivare al
punto nella tua volta ha ritenuto di
farmi tutti i livelli tutti tutti quindi
siccome non arriverò più al punto di
prima e questo è sicuro faccio il 2 così
a meno almeno qualcosa concludo
conoscendo il primo ragazzi non so che
cosa posso trovarmi davanti ma più o
meno ho un'idea e cos'è questo danno le
palline dell'altro non era così si è
partenza di merda che bello con iniziano
così technò si viva flussi ste si sia la
zio non sono tua sorella non so che cosa
pensi di me ma ti stai sbagliando
guardaroba che cazzo fatto però porca
[ __ ] va bene così ho capito che non ce
la farò mai più regala non importa siamo
livello da 50 quanti cazzo di livelli ci
sono che non aveva non avevo letto al 50
effettivamente era meglio che non lo
leggevo però va bene si fa farsi da
parte ma è impossibile ma qualcuno
voglia veramente di spiegarmi come si
dovrebbe fare questa parte ha forse così
facci tu a chiariamoci un secondo le
idee io arrivo lì sopra perché questo lo
devo fare per forza privato giu ma porca
[ __ ] ho già capito ma che cazzo sono
al livello che cazzo di iii livello 3
fantastico se ne mancano 47 no no se no
ci voglio neanche credere che sono
bloccato un terzo livello se se ganso è
non è possibile pensare per arrivare qui
minchia moglie alla fine ecco sarebbe
stato grande devo tornare indietro io
non pensavo dovessi tornare indietro può
arrivare in via trista roba credo cioè
tipo erano ben impossibile si calmi lega
si madonna l'ansia non aspettate un
attimo che ti porti ho perso dieci anni
di vita ma va bene palmi oddio non ci no
non lo so come ho fatto ma va bene è
successo un disastro cos'è sto schifo un
attimino che mi oriento un uomo a donna
che consuma più difficili un compito di
matematica e ce ne vuole aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta si si si
ecco come cazzo torni indietro è infatti
adesso
picchia cosa ha fatto cosa cosa ha fatto
sono morto a un rincoglionito però
qualcosa di decente la sto facendo
no si sibello madonna mia che bordello è
rega non si può fare anche un metodo e
vabbè dai ho capito no no no no si dal
bravo bravo la sorella del morire tuo
fratello il tuo cane il tuo criceto
sarei mai avuto il pulcino lemuri reti
anche l'erba in giardino calmi ok e
cielo rifatta fino a sto punto cosa
impossibile come ho fatto prima
sbagliare a natale giuro che non chiedo
niente ma ti prego fammi fare sta roba
minchia che culo ragazzi in giorno
sempre bellissima e ve lo voglio dire
però non ho capito bene perché sono
diventato verde credo che in un
formicaio ci sia meno casino però non ne
sono sicuro devi capire la tv che potrei
finire sto proprio perché mi sembra
impossibile ma io ci provo ugualmente
tipo adesso ecco nei fatti non son
riuscito neanche a prenderne uno invece
sì sì ok ok cagliari gatani 22 tuca tuca
che cola
ok rega 22 già presi cosa impossibile
ok si no si prega presi tutti un fatto
no no no si no porca [ __ ] mi sembrava
impossibile che ci sto riuscendo
non ce la farò mai più pary veramente
capire ma che la mente malata che crea
ste cose non perché non che card ma
proprio adesso vedere il naso [ __ ]
cazzo che culo ama stesso faremo con i
beni da papino che culo regalo slot dire
cos'è sta roba non è difficile questo
sembrano sempre abbastanza semplice poi
le ultime parole famose come cazzo fate
silver perfetto tipo partire quando loro
non ci sono tipo adesso si è mai
possibile
sì sì ok cani rega ho fatto non so che
non fate domande ma si può fare un
impossibile è impossibile questa musica
mi sta letteralmente tartassando le
biglie non so se per voi la stessa cosa
è roba che ci avevo da giocare proposto
schifo dovevo giocare sto schifo se non
votante di cosa invece no l'idea geniale
di giocare a sta merda su k è bello vai
bello ma è bello se mi son fermato però
ragazzo vinto nessuno si faccia domande
nessuno non ho capito neanche come ho
fatto per i vari soli qua ma porca
[ __ ]
no la kia casa e lì e lì tra con ed il
film perché devo farmi tutto no ma state
scherzando
ma se eri oggi mi devo fare tutto il
giro per fare due metri non è possibile
ok ok
eccolo eccolo una sedia per gli oli la
cina calmata perché impossibile fare sto
pezzo
si no caputo landia non è possibile ma
come cazzo si deve certo 150 morti in un
livello quasi manca non ci voglio
credere
ma bastano piano cina prima manca un
cazzo e muoio perché com'è che adesso ha
funzionato prima non ci ho messo 40
minuti non ci posso credere sono
arrivato dopo 276 morti fino a questo
punto che è una cosa impossibile e ho
capito che si va di difficile in
difficile ma cribbio che cos'è sta roba
fatemi capire devo no non si no porca
[ __ ] adesso tutto tutto me ne frega
niente
[Musica]
no no no ti prego
sì sì sì
sì
non me ne frega un cazzo del livello so
solo che sto lasciando l'anima e sto
gioco di merda su sto sudando usatemi se
no non riesco a prendere il primo ho
capito che devo fare è vabbè ci mette un
pochettino regalo e continuerò a
metterci un pochettino
si ok perché non chiedetevi come ho
fatto non lo so cagni che prova a fare
un'operazione di ricognizione cosa
difficile adesso non è anche prende una
ladra guarda che va bene mi fai fare un
stanchezza nel corpo negli occhi nel
cervello nella pazienza in tante cose
lo devo rifare cosa che non ci riuscirò
ma ci voglio provare a quanto precaria
la situazione ci riprova voglio le
redini del mondo
adesso devo fare tipo così
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] calmi ragazzi sono alla fine
sono alla fine sono così da mezz'ora
perché ciò paura di proseguire allora
allora calmiamoci un bel respiro tutti
quanti morire o così mentre faccia
mantini avevo già però ok ok ok ok
adesso grazie dio grazie moving
diagonale non c'è scritto diagonali ma
non importa
figlio mio santissimo una memoria siamo
a livello 10 452 morti non ma scusate
teorizzare un qualcosa di einstein è più
facile remake se no no no si fa cos'è
stato dio a ricami nabli safer o capi
sono fermo ma vi rendete conto che per
prenderne urbino non si riesce con
cuscini è una cosa pazzesca non si 111
va bene uno la band ritiro in salute
spiriti che per il resto della mia vita
non ne voglio più sapere va bene ragazzi
per adesso concludo che perché noi non
vorrei finire a capodanno perché chi
meno siamo lì però di continuare nel
prossimo episodio se riesco a arrivare
fino qualcosa che vedo difficile ma mi
ci metterò di impegno preghiamo in
cinese che qualcosa si riesca a fare
perché perché è assurdo che i ragazzi
come al solito servito mi è piaciuto lo
stesso argomento mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e condivido trattenendo
iscrizione dovrà sedersi scrivete che
noi ci rivediamo il prossimo mito della
ragazzi